another still and sunny day
another stream of little boats
another 252 people on saturday alone
it's a stream the government is
determined to stem
[Music]
but his latest plan to achieve that
sending migrants to rwanda has drawn
condemnation and now christian
intervention on the most important day
of its religious calendar britain's most
senior church leader with this
blistering assessment
the details are for politics and
politicians
the principle
must stand the judgment of god
and it cannot
subcontracting out our responsibilities
even to a country that seeks to do well
like rwanda
is the opposite of the nature of god
who himself
took responsibility for our failures
the plan is to send illegal migrants on
a one-way ticket here facilities in
rwanda where asylum claims can be
processed and people resettled
but there's been a huge backlash the
archbishops among the strongest
critiques while it isn't unusual for the
archbishop to comment on world affairs
this is a particularly pointed attack on
policy and while it's unlikely to cause
any change of course it does add weight
to the growing chorus of voices
objecting to the government's plans
and what he says may matter to the
tories while church influence is not
what it was the church of england is
still sometimes described as the
conservative party at prayer even here
in kent the county most affected by the
crisis opinion was nuanced and mixed i
think he was very
kind of
brave to say it
the feeling in the room you know he got
a bit of a round of applause at the end
you've got to do something about the
problem it's there and we've got to deal
with it
this is one way of dealing with it did
you think it was right for a religious
leader to intervene in policy in this
way sometimes i'm very dubious about it
i have to say my personal feeling is
politics and religion should
not mix but he did it in a brilliant way
the prime minister's called the plans
the morally right thing to do many of
his mps clear voters want such action i
think when justin welby makes comments
like this i just
actually
see a little bit of
naivety really i don't think he's in
step uh with his congregation i don't
think he's in step with the views of the
country but of course he's perfectly
entitled in a free and open democracy to
espouse whatever views he may have
it's emerged that the top civil servant
in the home office advised pretty patel
it was highly uncertain these plans
would deter people from coming
but scenes like these she says just
can't go on but the right way to stop
them now a matter for political and
moral debate helen and smith sky news
canterbury